in the forests of southeast asia high up
in the treetops a mythical creature
lives
it turns out
dragons
are real
so i have to call a biologist
i'm anthony russell from the department
of biological sciences at the university
of calgary in alberta canada we're
talking about a species of flying
lizards so it's called draco volans
which means flying dragon okay these
flying dragons they are a little
different from the dragons we see in
movies
for starters they're small they are they
are only about eight inches long
and they don't breathe fire
but they do fly
in a way
they're gliders which means they have
control of their descent and trajectory
but they don't have any power in it for
every one foot they go down in vertical
distance they'll be able to travel six
feet along that's because they don't
actually have wings they're actually
modifications of the ribs so they're
nothing to do with the legs and arms
evolutionarily speaking this has helped
the lizards survive
they can escape attacks and they have a
broader living zone so they might not be
dragon dragons sometimes people name
things because it's more dramatic effect
well they're still incredible lizards
actually no you know what i'm still
gonna call them dragons